a phrase that I heard over and over
growing up was this we ain't got no
money we ain't got no money for this we
ain't got no money for that was it true
probably not but it didn't matter
because I believed it and as an adult I
started kind of taking that on as my
status in life I ain't got no run I
ain't got no money so that's the reason
that I've got to borrow money uh I ain't
got no money so that's the reason that
there's limitations on my income it just
makes sense and I ain't got no money so
a budget probably wouldn't help me maybe
you've got that same I ain't got no
money thought of your own maybe it's
somebody like me just can't save money
or a budget could never help somebody in
my situation or whatever your exception
to the rule may be listen this is the
time to get your mind right man you got
to start challenging those thoughts